[Music]
on today's show we talk about stress and
its impact on marriages
and service and our weight we talk about
a marriage that is slowly ending
we also talk about a marriage that just
shot out with a bang during covid
and the flames are starting to die down
and they don't know what to do next stay
tuned
[Music]
[Applause]
hey what's up this is john with the dr
john deloni's show i'm so glad you're
here
glad you're walking along with us hope
you're having a good time hope
everybody's being nice everybody's being
cool
[Music]
i know they're not but let's just keep
saying it we're gonna keep putting out
into the universe over and over again
so glad you're here we're gonna talk
about mental health relationships what
did you
what what you can do next to make your
life what do you do what do you do
i can't talk this morning man so we've
been shooting these shows out of order
the last few weeks and so we're doing
them in the morning in the evenings
on saturdays and sundays that's not true
i just lied about that but we're doing
them all over the place
and um so we're all in here this morning
whenever you listen to this i don't even
know what time or day it's going to be
but
we're all here this morning early and we
are rocking and rolling but it's also
hard for me to get words out of my mouth
so
um bear with me so when we first started
the show
we if you go back to some of the
original og episodes
there's a lot of talk about the most
annoying thing in the world
and then i was like man there's so much
negativity out there
i want to stop being talking about
annoying things let's start talking
about positive things
well those days are over i'm sick of
that
because here's the thing there is people
just being annoying all over the place
and it's driving me crazy
and so we're going to bring some of that
back we're going to
bring annoying back yeah is that is how
you do that
okay so give me a call 1-844-693-3291
that's 1-844-693-3291
okay here's something that's been
driving me bananas about
earth i'll go back i think it was like
96 or 97 me and my friend tucker
you just it's when you just went to the
movies like
that was what you did you didn't
sometimes you went to see a movie but we
just went to the movies to see what was
playing what was what was open
and there was this movie out called
scream and drew barrymore who was
the fancy actress at the time she was in
the front of
you know all the all the promos we
didn't know anything about it
all right you had like watch a
commercial and then you watch
scream spoiler alert here drew barrymore
dies like in the first three minutes
and we i remember looking at each other
being like she's the main character
she's the big actress what do you
the big actress is supposed to go
through all the trauma and all the drama
and you know all the rules about horror
movies and then make it at the very end
she died in the first five minutes and
then it was wheels off you
never knew what was coming you thought
this person and that person and then the
ending of that movie was off the rails
it was awesome i just remember thinking
that's what a good movie is especially a
good horror movie it's one of my
favorite movies ever
for years he had no idea what was coming
right
nowadays when there's a funny movie
oh oh here's the other thing like will
ferrell would be in the movie or adam
sandler or
steve cor you just went and saw their
movie because you know it's gonna be
hilarious
now when there's a trailer for a new the
new kevin hart movie
all of the great jokes of that movie are
in the stupid trailer and then you get
in the movie
and that was it or even worse with scary
movies they'll say things like
and you'll never guess the ending well
now i know it's not going to be that guy
it's going to be that
stop giving it away listen and even with
stand-up
comedians stand-up comedians now have to
go
on all these internet podcasts and
promote their new special and they use
jokes and stories
that end up in the special and they're
the funniest jokes come on
let's bring some mystery back into the
world
like dating again right let's bring some
some mystery back and so now here's my
thing whenever i see a trailer for a
movie i just don't watch it
i just don't watch it because i don't
want to know if i see a trailer for like
a standard community i don't watch it i
don't want to know
i want to be surprised i want things to
be mysterious so stop ruining
trailers stop ruining movies stop
ruining it with these
over told trailers
and i know this sucks for comedians
especially because they got to come up
with all this new material
but you basically have to come up with
one set for for the show
and then another set for all this promo
otherwise you burn all the material and
it's not as funny anymore and i know
that's frustrating and annoying but
that's where we're at
so everybody let's bring some mystery
back into the world yeah
can you can you just say that after you
say bring anything back
no maybe if it was 2002
nope we're bringing sexy back mystery
back funny
we're gonna bring it all back bring
scary back and somebody has to go yeah
after every one of those things that's
the new rule
i'm i'm invoking that is a fantastic
album i just gotta say that
you know i've never heard it okay we'll
talk about earlier all right
all right we're done with that all right
let's go to the phones let's talk to
caleb
oh down the street here caleb from
nashville tennessee what's up caleb
hey how are you doing today good man i'm
doing so good how about you
i'm doing good i just listen to you talk
you sound
funny to me because i'm used to
listening to your show on two-speed so
your voice sounds a lot lower hey
puberty's wonderful man it's good
hey you'll get i did that
for i had my thing at either two speed
or one and a half speed when i was
listening to podcast
and i never forget the first time i it
accidentally i bumped it i guess and it
went to one speed
and i was listening to somebody and i
was like what is wrong with them or they
look like they've had eight bottles of
benadryl what's going on
so yeah it's cool just to have a regular
voice man
regular voice what's up caleb how can i
help man
all right so a few episodes ago wait
hold on hold on about
i bet i'm a disaster to listen to at two
speed i bet that's a lot
well it takes about 30 minutes to listen
to your show it's it's pretty
interesting but i get quite a bit out of
it still
my wife is always looking at me saying
hey slow down
we're all right here you don't have to
talk so fast i can't i'm gonna listen
i'm gonna try
i don't listen to this show cause i'm on
it i'm gonna try to listen to it too
speed all right caleb i'm interrupting
you go ahead man you just blew my mind a
little bit
all right so what's up brother all right
so a few episodes ago you're talking
about sleep
and uh needing to get seven eight hours
of sleep nine hours of sleep
uh my schedule has me where i'm waking
up around four o'clock in the morning
and i don't usually get to lay down any
at all
until about ten in at night i'm a my
vocational pastor
and so my early morning started around
five o'clock teaching uh
online english and then i also am a
father of six kids
and i i don't have a staff at my church
and so
trying to figure out is there a way what
i was thinking
is could i get six hours of sleep and
maybe catch up that other hour
throughout the day
is there a way that that would be
healthy i'm trying to get healthy i'm
like way overweight
okay so i'm trying to just really get to
i can be healthy
man i do you're a stud like on
five different levels um looks like you
are holding together a church in a
community and a family and
yourself and you're trying to make it
work and i'm i honor that dude that's
awesome
so backing me up a little bit before we
get to the sleep stuff
um because i'll answer that question
directly um
you say you want to get healthy man
you're way overweight tell me about that
all right so i'm 42 years old um 339
pounds
uh and so all right a couple years ago i
had a surgery i was i was at 443 pounds
okay
about 100 pounds yeah good for you
brother um so
trying to trying to still be that i've
got my youngest is two years old and i'd
like to
be around with his kids awesome so
so have you always been a big guy or is
this something in the last 10 15 years
oh you always have been okay
and how did you come to have a heart for
caring for other people so much
uh it's basically because of my dad
being in the ministry
i saw him he worked in a prison jail
ministry
and i saw him do a lot of things for
people and it just gave me a heart to
want to
help people out a lot awesome and you're
good at it too aren't you
well i don't know about that no you do
caleb
are you good at it i guess
oh good so good yeah um
no i bet you're real good at it so what
do you love about helping other people
well on the ministry side i love seeing
people where they're
growing and of course people getting
saved and
people growing on their christian walk
and things like that
um something about seeing the lights
come on whenever they're in yeah i was
coming out of that situation
less about the destination or the goal
what do you love seeing in people
when they and i love the way you said
that when just when the light comes on
suddenly they start seeing um freedom or
peace or they can make some some life
changes they can they can
they can change directions a little bit
right or they've been walking in a dark
tunnel and suddenly they see the light
so
you like being with people during that
process huh
yes and what about your
you got six kids what's how old's your
oldest
uh 16 16 it's 16 to
2 right yes wow
okay so to know what you love about
being a dad
i there's just so much they're uh i
enjoy
spending time with them which i don't
really get to do a lot of right now
but i love seeing them grow up and of
course
same thing with their as they're
maturing and growing and
them getting involved with the with
wanting to help people and
do things and just seeing that being
passed down the next generation of
people that's wanting to be involved
with helping people no matter what and
i just love seeing them grow and
the fun that we can have i can be silly
with my kids i can't be with anybody
else
i can be with my family how come you
can't be silly with anybody
else well because it's
a little bit although i my church they
let me be a little more silly than i
used to be so
they've actually pulled me out of my box
quite a bit i'm
quite a character most the time but when
i feel like
tense or pressure then i tend to put on
a good
uh what i think is a good game face
so uh
you and me are neighbors i don't know
you but you live in my community
and i
have spent a lot of time with folks in
your situation
so i'm setting that up to say can i be
super direct with you
yes as as though you and i are just
hanging out having a burger here in town
and you looked across the table and i
smiled at you and said
you want to go and you said let's go is
that cool
yeah so when you feel like you
are putting pieces of you away
so that you can put out this image that
you think other people want
and then they simultaneously see a 400
or
340 pound guy they see a guy who's
exhausted
they see a guy who is getting from thing
to thing and
um sits down he comes it they see
through that
facade right right and
as much as you want to be pretending
that it's all good and you got this
under control
there are not just the weight part
there's the other parts that
make their way out that's number one
the bigger thing is my bigger question
for you
is what is it about all these other
people
and i bet it's hundreds if not thousands
not to mention the fact that you're an
awesome dad and you love your kids what
is it about
them that is that
is more important to help and love and
serve
than in you
i for them i want to do whatever i can
for them
they're the future i'll give everything
i can for them
and you're exactly right and you're even
giving your present
so what is it about you that's not worth
that
same amount of investment that same
amount of care that same amount of
concern about the future
i i don't know i'm just too i guess i'm
too busy
what are you what are you busy from what
are you running from
you're asking some hard questions i know
i told you man we're just having a
burger
i know so here's here's what i've spent
years
behind closed doors with doctors and
lawyers and ministers yeah
and one of the you've probably heard me
say this over and over but addiction is
addiction is addiction
and we point fingers to drug addicts and
we put
fingers at sex addicts and pornography
addicts and you know
whatever addicts yeah we don't point
fingers at busy addicts especially those
who are making a million dollars
or especially those whose addiction is
helping other people so i don't have to
face myself in the mirror
and when i look at somebody who has
struggled with
caring for themself and has even gone to
the links of i need to get surgery i've
done 100 pounds dude that's a huge win
brother that's awesome
and but then the next step is this
stewardship of myself
this stewardship of this one precious
body that i got
that is that when it's okay when it's
fired on all cylinders
is gonna make me so much more available
for everybody else in the in my world
that i'm i'm interested in caring for
it's hard to slow down that addiction to
busy that addiction to helping others
and actually sit down and look in the
mirror and say
what is it about me that i don't think
is worth taking care of
right and so i ask you that what what
what is it about you
because you sound like an incredible guy
he's like a great father
my guess is you're a great husband my
guess is you're a great community member
what is it about you that caleb
is like you know what caleb's gonna come
last
i don't know i've always struggled with
low self-esteem i guess yeah
and so you've been a big guy i've always
wrestled with do people beat you up
about it when you're a kid they tease
you and you're a kid
uh yeah about lots of things but that
was definitely one of them
what else did they make fun of you about
well i was also
in school i was the president of the
bible club and so of course that didn't
exist
you're always the most popular so you're
a nerd the jesus geek and the
yeah and the the overweight kid what
else
what else right well
i i don't know there's a lot of those
were the big ones hey come on caleb
we're already in it now baby what else
well i they didn't teach me so much it
was more of myself putting pressure and
anytime i'd get i would go with my dad
when he would preach and i would sing or
play the trumpet
for him and there'd always be someone
that would say well you did good except
you didn't quite get this right yeah and
so always trying to help but
in the end um it made me a bigger critic
of myself
and what i'm doing uh then it did really
encourage me to help me
so when it rained bigger would it ring
true
if i said it sounds like
sometimes your desire to do ministry
your desire to help other people
is a continued desire chasing down
validation
uh yeah you're right you're right i've
been told that
okay whenever i see somebody who's
struggling with
caring for themselves and that is not
just that's not a that's not a weight
number okay it's somebody who i see in
their eyes or who tells me privately i
would love to love to love to get on the
floor and wrestle with my kids but i
can't get back up
i would love to love to love to go run
around in the yard with my kids but i
can't i can't run
i would love to love to love to have a
bowl of ice cream with my kids but if i
have one bowl i'm gonna have 17.
and so i just can't even go there
when i see that it makes me wonder
how i can help somebody turn that dial
to where they can look in the mirror and
say you know what
i'm worth being well i'm worth putting
on my oxygen mask i'm worth
dealing with the stress cycle and
letting it run itself through so that i
can
wake up and be whole for right
and so having six kids and being a
minister with no staff my guess is
money's pretty tight around your house
is that fair
uh yes okay so you're working 18 jobs to
duct tape this thing together right now
is that is that probably right
yes pretty close so sleep becomes a hard
priority
then health becomes a hard priority then
time becomes a hard priority and then
that whole cycle
and then money becomes our priority and
that thing just loops on itself
until at some point you pull the plug on
it and stop
and you say i'm going to scorch earth
this thing
and i'm going to build from the floor up
the life i want to have
the life i'm worth having not the life
that i'm just
tripping and stumbling towards until i'm
just going to collapse there at the end
right what i want it for more than
anything in the world
is for people with hearts like yours to
have a full night's sleep
to have people with hearts like yours to
have a bananas
awesome sex life hearts like yours to
have a bananas awesome
experience with their kids right not
saying you can't at 330 pounds you can
have all those things
but you're calling me and i'm in i'm
hearing you
you want something different and so the
question about sleep is a secondary
question or a
fifth down the road question to
caleb's worth being a steward of himself
and my guess is if you did some when's
the last time you went and saw a
counselor
uh um if you never have that's okay
brother
i was like six seven eight ten years ago
maybe what sent you what sent you to
counseling back then
uh it was an addiction i had uh
that i struggled with pornography years
ago
and so i went and my wife was with me
the whole way
she just wonderful lady but
we went together marriage counseling and
uh
the lord's brought us through that and
it's just
largely held but that was the last time
that we've been
did you did you trade that
addiction for something else
uh no not necessarily i guess i've got
more into the
helping more people trying to get more
busy doing things there you go so
so i would say sometimes you i meet
folks who
you know were addicted to drugs and then
they
get addicted to running marathons one is
infinitely healthier behavior
but sometimes you're not dealing still
with that root that says hey man you're
allowed to just sit down
right you're allowed to just go for a
walk and play with your kids and move
around
and roll around in the grass not to sing
running marathons is bad
right but sometimes we switch and that's
why i'm asking
um because i've jumped addiction to
addiction before
to addiction before and it wasn't until
i got to the root which was
i think i suck it was when i dealt with
that
that then i could work my way back up
your wife's a pretty awesome lady huh oh
she's
yeah not pretty awesome she is just
awesome what does she tell you about you
you're right
i'm sorry what does she tell you about
you
uh she is a she reminds me got a lot of
like you she's very straightforward
and so she uh she encourages me to a
point and then she realizes i'm having a
pity party and she'll just say caleb you
just need to
get up and and go on and i'm here for
you
yeah she does a lot of service to help
take
take off some of the pressure that i
have she's a stay-at-home mom
and takes care of all the things that
around the house and of course keeping
me on track is
is a thing of itself but is she is she
as much your
a maternal figure in your life as your
wife
oh my you know what my wife or my mom no
i'm saying is your
does your wife also function quasi as a
quasi mom too
does she make sure your laundry's done
and you're where you need to be and your
meals are made and
that you hey i need to make sure to some
degree to some degree but not
necessarily
okay um because i'm very i'm self
i can do that but more like keeping me
on hey you know there's
you got an appointment you got to do you
know you got a meeting and things like
that
okay so here's here's what i want you to
do caleb
[Music]
i want you to today
and this is gonna if you got time this
is gonna be a hard thing i'm gonna ask
you to do
okay i want you to get by
yourself for about an hour and i want
you to sit down
with a pen and a pad not a um you know
what i don't even care if it's a laptop
that's fine
if whatever works best for you but i
want you to write seven-year-old caleb
letter
and i want you to write him a letter
from
42 year old caleb i want you to
write to caleb and let him know the
things he should have heard
about how yeah he's a big boy but you
are awesome and
you are doing the best you don't can at
the trumpet for crying out loud
i want you to let him know that ministry
helping others
is not a performance it's not a way to
get validation because you don't need
validation because you're a good kid
what you need is a hug you need somebody
to tell you they love you
i grew up in the house my dad was a
detective half my life and a minister
the second half i've grown up in that
that world
and it can be exhilarating and it can be
really tough
right right and until you get to the
very core
here that caleb is
worth being well and wellness is an
action
it's not a it's not a it's not a state
of being it's it's a way of
living and then you begin to say
do i gotta get up at four o'clock in the
morning to do this one little thing so
that i can do that one little thing so
that i can stumble into this thing
or am i worth the full night's sleep am
i worth going for a walk every morning
and every evening because my breath is
worth it and my body's worth it and my
kids are worth it
am i worth laughing my head off and
being silly because that's just who i am
i'm a silly guy
and if they don't want to hire me then
so be it i'm a silly guy
i'm respectful and i show up but i do
good work and if that doesn't if that's
not enough then so be it
and can i be intimate and hold my wife's
hand during the day can i
am i worth being a steward of my body
and
being intelligent and smart about what i
put into it
not because i'm trying to hit some
arbitrary number that's going to make me
feel good
but just because i deserve to feel good
and when people chase numbers on the
scale they can get there
right there's that old tony robbins
saying like you can go to the hospital
and have them remove a leg
you can get to that number overnight
that's what we're trying to do
how can you lean in and slowly live a
life of just being well
right and then to answer your original
question
no you nee naps are good 20 minute naps
can be really really good
but you're aiming for seven eight hours
whole and so if you got to get up at
four
you got to go to bed a little bit
earlier and
you've got to lean on your kids and say
hey we're all going to bed a little bit
earlier now you're 16 you're 14 year old
their cycles are going to shift they're
going to stay up a little bit later and
that's going to be the way that is
um and forcing them to go to bed at
seven o'clock is going to be a nightmare
for everybody especially for them
um but your two-year-old should be in
bed early right your four-year-old
should be in bed early all
all of them should be getting 10 or 11
or 12 hours of sleep
and so it's not saying hey i've got all
this stuff to do how do i
manage sleep into that it is
how do i do all these other things
and honor my body and sleep well and
honor my relationships
so here's what i want you don't you
write that letter and i want you to get
somebody
close to you that you can be honest with
doesn't have to be a
a counselor it can be and i want you to
do the hard work of saying
i'm caleb i'm worth being well and i
want to go
all the way back i'm going to mine this
thing and i'm going to be well
i'm going to be free of any and all
addictions i'm going to help other
people because they deserve to be helped
not because i need to because i have to
i'm not going to go back to pornography
addiction because
i'm not trying to run from anything i'm
trying to hide from anything i'm not
going to be addicted to food no i can be
addicted to fill in the blank because
i'm just a guy who's a steward of his
body i'm a guy who's a steward of his
family i'm a guy who's a steward of his
job of his church of whatever it is that
you're doing
and that starts with you believing that
you're okay and that usually
it starts with having a community of
people around you somebody to look you
and i'd say
we love you just because you're caleb
right i'm so proud of your bravery i'm
so proud of your call i'm so proud of
you
walking this journey and here's the
thing you live in my community
come down and see me at the office one
day and we'll sit out here in the lobby
and have a cup of coffee and talk
i'd love to catch up with you man and
feel free to come on down and we'll set
that up sometime if you ever want to
just come and hang out i'd love to meet
you in person all right let's go to uh
emma in austin hey emma what's going on
how can i help
good morning how are you dr john what's
up emma how's it going
it's going pretty good um i um
i mean i say pretty good but that's what
everybody just jumps to right
so not not well right not not well um
i have had um a rough couple of months
and it just seems like the thing
i don't know just i hate to say the hits
keep coming but um
i need some help trying to find a corner
in the circular room that i can start to
try and rebuild
um where i'm at where my family's at
where my marriage is at
um so walk me through where i'm at
um about let's see no not about over
there's a lot of stuff leading up to
this but um a little back story
is when i was 24 my father passed away
suddenly
when i was 26 or 27.
my daughter had to have emergency heart
surgery ended up having to have five
heart surgeries and then so and then
anyway my father passed away right after
i was married then
my daughter needs all these surgeries
fast forward to now today
okay so that was like 10 years ago so
you're 37 now
i'm sorry you're 37 now no um
i am um yeah yeah 40.
37 21 right yeah exactly
perfect questions anymore
um the um so over thanksgiving
my husband who has been i knew was an
alcoholic
but he never admitted it finally
admitted it and we stopped drinking
okay and so that's good it's great right
i mean that's i've been so proud of him
and that's something that
i'm just you know it's the one thing in
my life and i'm like this is good
but at the same time you know it's been
a struggle because
you know he has to go through all of
these these challenges
um and then in january
um uh i found out i was doing some
research because i've been taking over
our finances
and i found out that he had stolen
approximately 72 thousand dollars out of
our 401k
technically okay but that's over
seven years like ten thousand dollars a
year
that he was sneaking and stealing and
you know just
to buy technically to buy the booze and
to buy
other stuff that he wanted and he always
told me it was called
gun money where i thought he was buying
guns fixing them up and selling them
and i really just gave him full you know
like i trusted him
i really trusted him um and then
recently like in the last couple of
weeks he
he got an offer oh he he also quit so he
was in the alcohol industry
and now he's um he went and then he
switched over to olive oil or some
another commodity which i was like super
excited about that he wasn't happy
and now we just got a new opportunity to
take a job
in the alcohol industry again um but he
says it's his dream job
and i told him that i was you know had
my reservations and
um and he took it anyway so but the
problem with the job
is it's like five and a half hours away
so we have to move
to be there and i feel like it's just a
lot i mean that's just
in a short period of time like i mean i
don't know if i've ever
i mentioned my father and my daughter
because i don't know if i ever got over
that
you know so it just feels like
everything was like what i could have
put away to this side i may have to deal
with now
and all of this with my husband how many
kids do you have
we have three children how long have you
been married
uh 18 years
is um going to get right to it is your
marriage over
i don't i don't know i don't think so
you don't think so
but does he think so no he doesn't think
so
he is 100 let me ask you this way
you've let him do for a decade
yeah he was an alcoholic and you knew it
and you let it well he was just
functioning he was just like it was it
was like more like
hey i'm gonna go sit by the fire and
drink till i fall asleep
right so like i said you knew it and
yeah right when you're married to an
alcoholic
that impacts your intimate life that
impacts your sleep life it
impacts your well hey that's just dad
life it impacts your kid it impacts
everything
even if they're a functioning alcoholic
it impacts everything and it just
becomes that's just the way he
is but you knew it and i'm not blaming
you i'm just
laying it out here so that you can see
his perspective
he's been able to do whatever he wants
and then he just made an extra 10 grand
every year taking money from the
family's future
to do whatever he wants because he's
been allowed to do whatever he wants
and yeah
here's what i know i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna blame you i'm not gonna
shame you anything like that
one month or two months if my wife's
like hey i got some extra this or
something
cool that's a thousand bucks a month
that's 800
a month or whatever yes over 10 years
and so he robbed you for 10 years and
you chose to look the other direction
for 10 years
and now you're not blaming you i'm just
saying
from his perspective he runs this house
he does whatever he wants whenever he
wants
right and now he's just taking another
job
that's going to kill him that's going to
go back to the way things were in
another town
and you know what y'all are just going
to get in the boat and come along
because that's the way it works
and so when i ask you is your marriage
over
that's what i'm asking you and what i'm
saying is
is it just going to be the way it was or
is this the moment when you say no more
because if it's the way if it's just the
way it's gonna be then it's just the way
it's gonna be
and if you're gonna say you know what
not this time i'm not moving this time
i'm not i'm not going to go back to
having you be an alcoholic working in
this environment i'm not going to
just pretend that you didn't put us in
the hole 75 000
times compound interest over a decade
times over three decades which is a lot
of money
it makes me sick because i'm all about
financial stability
right and you had to be about financial
stability because you weren't about
relational stability
your dad poof was a vapor right you
almost lost your baby
several times right you lived in the
shadow of a functioning alcoholic
right and so financial security became
the thing you could control
and even that got slipped through your
fingers right
exactly and we're living in our dream
house right now i'm trying to fix
it you know um and during all this time
we knew we were going to do foundation
repair on it so i started all this
foundation repair
he's he's working monday through friday
you know five and a half hours away good
news is he's living with his parents
so and his parents are and i are kind of
on the same page they don't know about
the embezzlement embezzlement
but they do know about the alcohol and
um what did he say when you confronted
him about the money
um he he
like he took full responsibility
and i asked him i said i think you need
to research and find out how much it is
i said but you need to know that i'm
going to research and find out how much
it is
so he researched and found out 32 000
when i researched
i found out the 72 because i'm really
good with finances and i can find out
when people are taking money
i know i know but listen okay so let's
pretend you and i
are having coffee and i showed up okay
and i said my husband's stealing from me
when i called him on it he lied about it
he went on this big i'm so sorry
expedition i'm gonna find out how much
he lied by half
he's been an alcoholic he finally got
away from it
and then he just packed up and moved
five and a half hours away in with his
parents
and took another job and what would you
tell me
emma your marriage is over it's on the
rocks
it is drowning this isn't about
foundation this isn't about
money thievery this isn't about it's
about
are living two completely separate lives
and you've got a picture that you are
taking bits of information
and trying to um put it this way it's
like a puzzle
and there's missing pieces and so you
have a piece of construction paper
underneath this puzzle and you're
coloring it in trying to make it the
puzzle
work together and it's not
because he just keeps taking more pieces
because he can take whatever he wants
and at some point you got to get a car
and y'all got gotta meet
probably with somebody and you gotta
just put it out there and say do you
wanna be my husband
because if you wanna be my husband this
is what it's gonna look like
right i do wanna have a relationship
with him i just wanna be able to work
this out i mean i just
but he's got to be able to want to do
that too
yeah he says he does he he says he does
i know but then he
i know but behavior is a language
yeah he says he does and then he took a
job five and a half hours away moved in
with his parents and got back in the
alcohol industry
yeah the reason he also took the job is
because it makes more money sure
great the money that he took
but listen when i wasn't well my wife
and i took a 70 000
household pay cut to move to a new city
and i took a new job so we could i could
get well so she could get well so we
could heal our marriage
great i don't care how much money he's
making i don't i'd rather him quit
and go work at starbucks and rebuild
himself and your relationship from the
floor up
together with you not
not be further deceitful not be further
selfish not
further put you guys relationally back
even further
in order to chase down this money and
try to get it back and man
no way jose dude
you got to just somebody's got to throw
the flag on this deal turn all the
lights in the stadium on
and y'all got to walk out and meet at
the 50-yard line and say what are we
doing
i want to be your wife you say you want
to be my husband and here's the world
we're living in
because a a team who has here's the
other thing
after he stole from the family
stole from your kid's future stole from
y'all's future
and then lied about it and then took
another job
you'll have to rebuild something new
you're not just going to get back to the
way things were and by the way the way
things were were no good he was a
functioning alcoholic that you let do
whatever he wanted to do
you guys got to build something new
and then he packed up and moved and left
you to deal with the foundation and
three kids and and
and and so you all have to
get in a room excavate what was
because what was is gone and decide do
we want to get an
architect an engineer and a builder and
build something new
and if we do what is that going to look
like that's going to look like a couple
that makes
five-hour moves to gather decisions
together we take new jobs together we
raise our kids together
we rise and fall with your sobriety
together
you don't conspire with his parents to
keep an eye on him he's a grown man he
can do what he wants to and he's been
able to forever
so here's the thing your marriage it's
not over i shouldn't have said it like
that
it is on a ventilator it's on a
ventilator
it is gasping for air and i want to see
you
um turn all the lights on the hospital
and pull the hoses out and say we're
gonna make this thing right
all right thanks for that call emma um
y'all got a lot of work to do
let me know how that journey goes um but
make that call this weekend let's get on
it
okay all right uh real quick i get this
i got this email
what is catastrophizing it's one of
those
geek words that i use sometimes here's
what catastrophizing is
plain and simple it's when you
dream up think through
look at one headline another headline
one
facebook post uh something that your
friend tells you at the water cooler or
grabbing coffee or text you
and you come up with the worst case
scenario that could ever happen and then
that scenario becomes
fact back underneath you so for instance
man home prices have risen 15 percent in
my local community
and we just printed and gave away
i don't know a couple of trillion
dollars just just cause we just gave it
away just mail it to people's mailboxes
because we just make up money in america
and um if you read some reports
the uh covet stuff has fallen off the
map the the world's opening back up it's
going to be a race and if you
read some reports we overheated the
economy by printing money and we're
going to have a big collab we're going
to have
so here's the thing catastrophizing is
looking at that data
and saying i got to get chickens and a
cow and a bunch of bullets because it's
all coming down
it's it's the end of time or last night
a tornado warning came through
our community and i got the little buzz
on my phone
i could have my heart starts beating
when that happens i grew up in houston
there's a lot of hurricanes
so i've been through some bad storms
catastrophizing is
oh my gosh we're all gonna die how am i
gonna and i start planning out how i'm
gonna tell my in-laws that my wife and
my kids have passed away
i go to the worst case scenario becomes
true and i start
acting on those things and they're not
true
most of the time they're not so here's
two things you can do
to push back against catastrophizing
number one call it out
and if you can't call it out run ideas
by a buddy
a few years ago i called my buddy as a
banker todd and i said
hey i think it's all coming down i need
to move all my stuff into gold
i need to move all my stuff into bullets
and guns and coffee and
beef and he said hey just so you know
if it ever goes down to where we are
trading gold and cigarettes
your neighbor will have tried to shoot
you for your water and
it'll be a whole diff and i was like oh
yeah that would get real yeah we would
have no food you'd be eating your grass
in your yard
that's catastrophic having a a somebody
in your community that will
bounce your ideas off of you the other
thing is
turn off noise turn off nonsense if
you've got somebody in your life that's
always like oh did you know
did you know this shut up i'm i'm
cutting that off
i quit reading the news i quit watching
the news because the news sells
catastrophe
because it makes me go back and it makes
me go back there's parts of my brain
that are always searching the
environment for catastrophe to keep us
alive
and that's what news sells it's
catastrophe it doesn't sell facts it
sells catastrophe
so i cut it out i cut it out if i have
an economic question
i get to sit by dave ramsey on the show
so i ask him
hey is this real and he's like that's
not real i said is this real and he's
like yeah that's real pretty scary
or i call my friends who are doctors or
lawyers or you've heard me talk about
that before
so cut it out right cut it out
we like to catastrophize and think
through plans because it feels like
we're doing something we're not we are
sending our body into fight
or flight we are pulsing these chemicals
through our body
that are slowly killing us
catastrophizing kills us
slowly long tail suicide i just think
about the worst thing ever
so get a group of people around you that
you can bounce ideas off of that you can
go back and forth with it and say no
that's a big deal we should be worried
about that and
yeah i guess we could all get hit by a
tornado tomorrow and i'll die how about
we plan for that when it happens
i got a will i've got a group of people
who love me
and let's plan for that when it happens
until now let's just sit down in the
basement our flashlights and play
flashlight tag with the kids how about
that
right so you get to choose whether you
meditate and focus on these things
so that's catastrophizing hey i want to
take a quick break and talk about
something important your
mental health if you cannot find an
in-person counselor in your area or you
can't afford one i've got a solution
i've partnered with better help for
customized online therapy
for you video chat phone or even
text chat counseling with licensed
therapists
that are going to help you become a
better version of yourself
help you get on the road to being well
go to betterhelp.com for 10
off your first month this is less
expensive than traditional therapy
and you're worth it betterhelp.com
take care of yourself start today all
right let's take one more call let's go
to esther
in new york city what's up esther good
morning dr
john it's a pleasure and an honor to
talk to you i'm delighted by your
existence i listen to your podcast
all the time thank you for sharing your
time and wisdom with us oh my gosh i
can't believe it i'm on the show
you're like hey you're my favorite
person ever i
like oh my gosh you're the best thanks
for calling so what's up you just made
my whole morning what a joy oh
thank you uh you make my morning a lot
so i'm glad that i can do the same for
you
you did what a joy so how can i help you
thank you
um so my question is what is your advice
for newlyweds who didn't have a good
model for marriage growing up
so my husband and i recently got married
for me our relationship had the ideal
progression despite
an ideal circumstances we were
introduced by a mutual friend and we
went to the same parties we
were purely platonic friends for a
couple of months got
interested in each other not too long
after the friendship began
not to make it weird became official
then
got married admittedly the courtship
process was
fed up from us being the only constant
constant
in-person interaction we both had he's
my first and my last boyfriend
so hold on just so everybody can hear
you i can tell in your voice you are a
laser of passion is that right
right and then the world shut down and
you could see no one
no people in new york city but then you
saw this one
and all right go ahead we actually got
together a few months
before kovid started so i think i got a
good apocalyp
buddy ah there you go and then man that
laser burned on one dude one time all
the time
and he was a great absorbent of that of
that laser
and that thing burned hot and fast quick
is that right
yeah i think it was survival of the
fitness in terms of relationships in
2020 the fact that we got married after
being together
that intentionally like we made it
i guess i guess that was a good litmus
test
all right so how can i help um
the high war off is that where we're at
no it's not that it's actually me just
wanting to make sure that we spend the
rest of our lives together as much as
possible
thank you a challenge i'm experiencing
is that we're an interracial
and an interfaith couple and our mothers
have strongly expressed their
disapproval of us getting into an
interracial
and interfaith relationship throughout
our lives we have a lot of differences
he was born and raised in new york and i
grew up in asia
and i moved to america when i was an
adult and i'm still getting used to the
new york culture and american life
um similarities we have we both don't
have anything to do with our parents
anymore so for me
it's making our marriage feel very
lonely in that sense that we didn't have
a good
model so in both our cases one parent
passed away
due to terminal illness and the other
parent is no longer
in our lives no longer has any bearing
on our lives
in fact i've totally cut out my living
parent because it was so toxic around
them that i actually had to run away
from my physical safety
so yeah my husband and i both grew up in
religious households
in which religion was justified was used
to justify abuse
so personally i have experienced the
whole chibang really the emotional
physical um everything that's actually
why i had to run away from home and it
made me
quite frankly hate men the fact that i
got married is really a miracle
you know what though esther it's not a
miracle it was a life raft
and when you walk through all of these
challenges that you just
put out there
a interfaith inner racial
parents have abandoned you you're still
getting used to a new culture
you are an abuse survivor you are a
religion a religious abuse survivor
you still have some faith he's got no
faith whatever
you guys have you guys have got high
together
you guys got high and you tried to solve
all of your problems with one another
and one another
can't solve each other's problems like
that and that got intense and that got
quick and that got heavy and that got
and now it's getting very very real okay
so here's here's what i want you to
think through okay esther
this is a um one of those things like if
someone says hey how do i lose weight
you just go die and exercise
sounds really simple but it's really
hard okay
are you ready yeah all right
you number one have to get some models
in your life
you've got to invest intentionally
in couples who have been married longer
than you that you want to emulate
it'd be great if they were interfaith
it'd be great if they were interracial
because they could understand some of
those complexities that y'all are going
to have to navigate together
but having a couple of models would be
ideal here's the second thing
you guys have to get some community
you're going to burn each other up
because the other person cannot handle i
lost my mom because of you i lost my
faith because of you i'm losing part of
my culture because of you i'm losing
part of my
ethnic and racial heritage because of
you that will melt each other
that you're a laser beam and my guess is
he is too
or he's a recipient of a laser and at
some point that just burns
so you got to get other people in your
life whether that's my preference would
be some really close
wonderful friends that you can share
life with and ebb and flow and move with
and here's the last thing you all have
to do
really hard work building a picture of
what tomorrow's gonna look like
and practice living into it here's what
i mean by that
you guys were on fire y'all practice
safety right is he a good friend is he a
good buddy
is he a good romantic partner we're
practicing safety awesome
awesome awesome then you achieved safety
you you said that guy's safe enough i'm
gonna marry
he said she is on fire and i love her
and she's safe enough to marry
now here's what you have to practice
you've to practice
desire you have to practice doing things
that are going to make you uncomfortable
but he is going to
love and he's going to have to do vice
versa and when i say uncomfortable i
mean
i want to yell and i want to scratch him
i want to punch him in the face i'm not
going to do that i'm going to hug him
he knows that i'm going to he's going to
want to call his mom and he's not going
to do that because you've asked him not
like
so when i say uncomfortable i don't mean
unsafe and i don't mean violating any of
your
your boundaries i mean you each
each other each of you are going to wake
up every day saying how can
i practice intimacy practice
desire how can i make sure that kitchen
is spotless how can i make sure
that laundry is done how can i make sure
that lunch is made whatever those little
little tiny tasks are
and that comes from you learn those from
models you learn those from
deep conversations you learn those from
developing a picture
of what tomorrow is going to look like
where do y'all want to be what's the
what's the marriage model you want to
have we want to have
laughter we want to go dancing we want
to we want to make
decisions together we want to have
children that are going to grow up
safe in a loving life but also know the
the harmful realities of living in new
york it's a biracial couple's interfaith
couple
we want kids who can navigate different
faith perspectives but also land on
this one plate we want all those things
and then you just got to reverse
engineer it that means we have to talk
about faith
when we run into cultural differences
we're not going to blow up we're not
going to go to war we're going to sit
down and say
huh in asia we did it like this and he
says well
in new york we did it like this how can
we make this work for both of us
and it's going to take a process of
learning it's going to take a process of
somebody calling saying hey we're in a
bad dance we're in a dance where we are
we've looped back into old patterns i'm
calling it so so the flag
let's all back out right let's go back
in and again let's go back in again
and you're going to practice and
practice and practice and this is
something you're going to practice
forever and there's going to be seasons
when the desire
is rich and he's the hottest guy you it
is going to burn and esther is going to
be back on fire
and there's going to be days that you
are cold as ice and you're going to have
to practice
you have to practice and then he's going
to say something or you're going to do
something and that safety is going to
wear thin you have to practice safety
again
you're going to have to this is the
dance of relationship and i want you to
know that if you do practice it
and you do find good models and you do
have good community and you do take care
of each other
and you take care of yourselves it's all
so worth it
it's also worth it you end up at
whatever day
your day here is done you have no tread
left on the tires you've laughed every
laugh you're gonna have you've hugged
every hug you're gonna have
you've had every romantic night you're
gonna have your kids have had every
celebration and every heartache and
every heartbreak and you've grieved
deeply and deeply deeply and you've
risen from the ash
and he's watered that ash so that you
can rise and vice versa and vice versa
and vice versa
but it starts with a community starts
with a model
and it starts with you and him sitting
down saying where do we want this to go
what is it going to look like
specifically where's the tv going to go
where are we going to live
how are we going to talk to one another
and then we're going to reverse engineer
that and get there
and i love your heart ester
so good so good so good after you have
that first conversation call me back and
let me know how that goes
all right as we wrap up today's show
just gonna get right into it it's one of
the greatest albums of all time the
greatest songs of all time
and i know my friend preston here thinks
they're awesome they just are what they
are
1997 self-titled album third eye blind
this is the background and it goes like
this
everything is quiet since you're not
around and i live in the numbness now
in the background and i do the things we
did before i walk height street to the
store and they say where's that crazy
girl
you don't get drunk on red wine and
fight no more i don't see you anymore
since the hospital
and the plans i make still have you in
them because you came swimming into view
and i'm hanging on your words like i
always used to do
the words you use so lightly i only feel
for you
and i only know because i carry you
around in the background and i'm in the
background
in words they come and memories all
repeat and i lift your head while they
change the hospital sheets
and i would never lie to you no i would
never lie to you now
i felt you long after we were through
the plans i make still have you in them
because you came swimming into view
in the background who who doesn't like
them
preston this has been the dr john
dolone's show
[Music]